when you eat food passes from your mouth
into your esophagus a muscular tube that
leads to your stomach
your esophagus has a ring of muscle at
the end called the lower esophageal
sphincter
it opens to let food into your stomach
normally it stays closed to prevent
stomach contents from going back up into
your esophagus
if the sphincter doesn't close all the
way gastroesophageal reflux or ger can
happen
the weak or relaxed sphincter allows the
contents of your stomach to reflux
or leak back into your esophagus
acid in the stomach contents irritates
your esophagus
this can cause a painful burning feeling
in your chest called heartburn or acid
indigestion
it's common to have gastroesophageal
reflux once in a while
however if it happens more than twice a
week for a few weeks you may have a more
serious condition called
gastroesophageal reflux disease also
known as gerd
if left untreated gerd can lead to
complications over time
for example you may develop esophagitis
where the lining of your esophagus
becomes inflamed or irritated
your esophagus may become too narrow
which is a condition called esophageal
stricture
gerd may cause you to breathe stomach
acid into your lungs
this can lead to respiratory problems
such as asthma chest congestion
hoarseness wheezing laryngitis and
pneumonia
gerd can also lead to a condition called
barrett's esophagus
in this condition the cells lining your
lower esophagus are replaced with cells
similar to those in your intestine
this may increase your risk for
developing cancer in your esophagus
common causes of gerd include
being pregnant or overweight which puts
pressure on your abdomen
smoking
certain medications such as those that
treat allergies high blood pressure and
depression
and a hiatal hernia a hiatal hernia is a
condition where the upper part of your
stomach moves up through an opening in
your diaphragm
this makes it easier for stomach acid to
come up into your esophagus
the most common symptom of gerd is
heartburn
other symptoms include nausea problems
swallowing bad breath hoarseness
sore throat and bringing food back up
called regurgitation
to find out more about gastroesophageal
reflux disease talk to your health care
provider
this animation is brought to you by the
nucleus medical art library or enmol
where you can download this animation
and thousands of medical images and
videos created by nucleus medical media
to apply for a free 30-day trial click
on the link in the description